[Musica]
salve mi chiamo karim e questo è il mio
mondo
il mio lavoro principalmente consiste
nel vestirmi in modo ridicolo per il
vostro giubilo personale ma soprattutto
creare intrattenimento partendo quasi da
zero in qualunque forma e con qualunque
mezzo ma ogni tanto la vita mi dà una
mano regalando mie emozioni che soltanto
una mente umana potrebbe mai concepire
la storia che voglio raccontarvi oggi ha
tutti gli elementi per essere un nuovo
canto di natale un punto di riferimento
da raccontare i nostri nipoti questa è
la maxi storia di come la mia vita è
cambiata capovolta sottosopra sia finita
per colpa di un'applicazione il 2016 è
stato l'anno di pokemon gol
ve lo ricordate no quel gioco che c'ha
spara frecciate talmente tanto che è
riuscito a portare alla distruzione la
vita di alcune persone c'è addirittura
un sito che tiene conto di tutti i morti
ei feriti causati da questa app pokémon
gode tracker puntocom wish you a merry
crisis tenendo conto che pokémon go è
basato sulla tecnologia di ingresso è
diventato talmente popolare che ha fatto
trasformare le pupille di alcune persone
in piccolissime simboli di dollaro dando
vita ad un incantevole copia incolla
giurassico ward a live che permette di
catturare i dinosauri ghostbusters world
che permette di catturare i fantasmi
garcin goti permette di catturare i
garfield tirando pezzi di lasagna nella
loro ciotola nel 2018 la gente pensava
di guidare auto volanti ma ci siamo
vicini molto vicini si stanno
avvicinando le festività natalizie ma
voi non avete ancora idea di cosa
regalare alle persone a voi care vi
presento follo un jesus christ di noi
avrete sicuramente sentito parlare
perché ha creato parecchio scalpore il
gioco che ti permette di catturare i
santi le battute si sono sprecate le
critiche ancor di più perché con delle
premesse del genere sarebbe molto facile
cadere
sotto alla fede o alla religione di una
persona io al contrario sono curioso di
sapere cosa ne pensino proprio le
persone difende di una cosa del genere
perché tutti quando sono uscite le
notizie hanno gridato allo scandalo ma
veramente veramente pochi l'hanno
provata
d'altro canto dare aria alla bocca è
molto più facile che alzare il culo è
vero quindi l'ho provata io per voi
nonostante il gioco asserisca essere in
inglese e in realtà è completamente in
spagnolo
cerco di districarmi tra i menu e riesco
a trovare nuova partita mi chiede di
compilare un micro questionario sulla
mia diocesi e la mia parrocchia e quindi
faccio quello che avrebbe fatto chiunque
vado nel panico ma fortunatamente si può
bypassare tutto quanto in forno ucciso
skies lo puoi scegliere il tuo avatar
e adesso vi faccio ridere questo è in
secondo avatar disponibile scelgo questo
come funziona il tutto è molto semplice
camminando per strada trovi varie icone
quelle di cattura sono invocazioni alla
madonna santi e martiri e personaggi bbc
e quindi vi chiederete come si catturano
i santi rispondendo il vero falso paura
loro domanda semplice diretto in
spagnolo
se la risposta è quella corretta
entreranno a far parte della vostra
squadra
io sono riuscito a trovare jesús emilio
ara millo quello che più mi ha intrigato
però sono le tre barre di fame sete e
fede che tu devi riempire trovarlo delle
monete di pane vino e fede per strada e
questo trasforma fondo gesù skies in un
survival cazzola religione può essere
brutale a volte invece in caso di
risposta errata il gioco mi chiederà di
riprovare al costo di tre monete che si
possono trovare sia in giro sia
acquistare con soldi veri tramite micro
transazioni che in gioco chiama
azioni o comunque tralasciando la
questione di nero trovo che l'app sia
estremamente innocua che non sia questa
tragedia che tutti si aspettavano che
fosse quando sono usciti tutti questi
articoloni e titoloni da prima pagina
anzi vi dirò di più per una fetta di
pubblico probabilmente molto molto
giovane e potrebbe anche esserci del
vago intrattenimento dentro pure le
recensioni sono positive certo sono
state scritte da jesus l'over 6000 e
forni for jesus col con una faccina del
demonio quindi non credo siano proprio
attendibilissime ma io sono agnostico
non posso capire quanto questa cosa
possa effettivamente pesare su una
persona di fede quindi mi rivolgo a voi
una cosa del genere è forse troppo
e ricordiamoci che è stata approvata da
papà francesco in persona
lui e social media manager di dio quindi
è come se l'avesse approvata dio l'ha
considerata per blasfemia ormai un
pizzico di blasfemia si trova ovunque
uno per esempio per festeggiare il
natale no la nascita di gesù non va in
un negozio a comprare un bella bobo e
ritorna a casa con gigetto il babbo che
muove il culetto
io personalmente non credo che ci suo
avrebbe mai approvato una cosa del
genere dopo tutto quello che ha passato
pure in dovrebbero fare dei piccoli
adesivi con scritto approvato da ponzio
pilato e appiccicarlo su questo tipo di
addobbi secondo me questo può essere
considerato blasfemo
non lo so ma mi fa ridere come uno
stronzo
[Musica]
io ho un sogno visto che siamo riusciti
a catturare dinosauri fantasmi e santi
mi piacerebbe andare oltre vorrei essere
capace di programmare per creare l'app
dei miei sogni non più vip o vorrei
poter andare in giro a catturare fip che
la televisione non si caga più da anni
ma che ci hanno accompagnato tra gli
anni 80 fino ai primi del 2000 sogno di
trovare ana laura ribas e collezionarle
lanciandole addosso un assegno a sei
zeri
immaginate di poter trovare dei beppe
braida unirli e farli evolvere in un
pippo franco non vedrei l'ora di
camminare in città alla ricerca delle
sorelle lecciso shiny senza dimenticarci
dei non più vip leggendari magari farli
apparire solo in eventi specifici dove
tutte le persone possano riunirsi sotto
la stessa passione comune catturare e
marco columbro ma per lui servirebbe
l'equivalente della master ball un
contratto mediaset a che sogno è questo
di cui parlava martin luther king e
secondo me a posto